J Balvin how are you man grateful man
great huh Felicia Lama is thank you so
much I mean you really are the man of
the night the most nominations at the
Latin Grammys with a how are you feeling
dawg
I feel grateful man that's the does
world grateful and thankful yeah you
know it's been a rollercoaster year when
you look back on it what will you
remember the most Wow I remember the
Moses that all dreams will come true and
then I had a lot of dreams this year
when we started and and we made them
happen and we're gonna keep dreaming
more and more yeah you collaborated with
some of the biggest artists in the game
especially this year I mean is there one
in particular you're like I'm so happy
that that happened that we made it work
Wow you know this a lot you know we did
they were hot 100 number one we've gotta
be but Bonnie my boy you know you know
the fact that we were the most extreme
artists in the planet - there's a lot of
blessings man to happen this year yeah
absolutely
not to mention Beyonce ain't calling you
to hop on any hamp the agreement and
Coachella like have you heard from queen
bee at all tonight has she wish you well
and good luck have another but I know
her from it you know her team is so cool
with me yeah you know I got a little of
her name
you know everybody is dying to work with
you but who you wanted to collaborate
with next you know Drake is one of my
favorite ones the weekend absolutely
rihanna of little more no post Malone
some other artists that I love it you
name it so laughs yeah I hear you might
have a surprise collapse tonight on the
stage at the Grammys oh really okay huh
what can we expect for your performance
tease it for us oh right my yeah that's
all we want to do leave it up and real
quick how you gonna celebrate if you win
man you might you have a good shot man
we might bomb any with my people and we
might seem since they want
[Music]